[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
على مدى السنوات العشر الماضية التي قرأت فيها
عن هذه الرحلات
وسمعت عنها من
جدي ومنذ ذلك
الحين كان طموحي طويلاً أن أتيت إلى
هنا  في الوقت الذي جاء فيه جاك جدي الأكبر
إلى هنا ، كان عام 1912 وكان سبب
قدومه هو التحقيق في تجارة اللؤلؤ
حقًا لأن هذا هو الوقت
الذي كانت فيه اللآلئ هي أثمن
الأشياء في العالم كما تعلمون
اكتشاف مناجم الماس في الجنوب
قصدت إفريقيا
أن الندرة النسبية لم يعد الماس نادرًا
جدًا ، لذا كان ذلك يعني أن كومة واحدة
تساوي أربعة أضعاف كمية
الماس وكارتييه في هذه المرحلة ، كان
كارتييه براذرز جاك الثلاثة
وشقيقاه لويس وبيير حقًا
في محاولة لبناء
متجر صغير لصائغ المجوهرات الباريسي لجدهم إلى
شركة مجوهرات رائدة في العالم كان ذلك
طموحنا ، فلنقم ببناء شركة مجوهرات رائدة
في العالم جيدًا
كيف تفعل ذلك من خلال امتلاك  أفضل
قطع المجوهرات في العالم وما
هي أفضل قطع المجوهرات
كانت جواهر اللؤلؤ ، لذلك كان الأخوان
مثل أين نجد أفضل اللآلئ
في العالم
أم لا يجب أن نذهب إلى الفتاة التي
لا يقل دخلها عن 60 من دخل كارتييه
من مجوهرات اللؤلؤ الضخمة
التي تعلمون أنها كانت تصنع جميع أنواع
الأشياء من الساعات إلى الساعات إلى
علب السجائر حتى تعرف الماس
جواهر ولكن الغالبية العظمى جاءت من
اللؤلؤ الذي يوضح مدى أهمية
هذا الرابط ومدى أهمية
تلك الرحلة التي قام بها جاك  الذي تم إجراؤه هنا
هو أنه لم يأت فقط لشراء الأحجار الكريمة
في تلك الرحلة التي أرادها أن يفهم
التجارة وما وجدته أيضًا مثيرًا للاهتمام
هو أنه أراد حقًا
مقابلة الأشخاص الذين يفهمون هنا ثم
الجلوس معهم لتناول الطعام  لهم
[موسيقى] أجنبية